later honor is like definitely a
directors movie with a very powerful
vision and aesthetically it was a
revolution at the time and so we had to
relate to the main qualities of that
movie and enough same time we'll have to
find our own identity of this new movie
I brought it on board Roger Deakins
right from the start and we spent
several weeks in Montreal drawing what
will be the foundation of the movie the
laws the logic the aesthetic basis it
was a journey what do you want I wanna
ask you some questions for me cinema is
not about dialogue it's about
choreography be a dance between sound
and images I took several visual
liberties from the first movie I felt
that we should be quite close to the
spirit of the Sun design so we work very
hard to bring that kind of impression
istic artificial quality to the
atmospheres there's always some kind of
sounds that we'd never heard before that
are coming from technology that we don't
know that are carefully blended with the
music we had figure out a way to make
sure that it will be a standalone that
added so people could appreciate the
story for itself even if they had not
seen the first movie I think that it's a
good idea to see the first movie first
because it's a fantastic film but if you
don't you can still enjoy the moon
[Music]
[Music]